il ya un ouragan qui arrivent il faut
pas tardé ajoute encore been pour le
rapport
si son millions en raison d'échangés
tout est là avec environ 300 millions de
cette petite fête
c'est en responsabilité je suis assez
doué pour faire la baby sitter de vie
qui fait partie de ces chasseur
d'ouragans
ouais je fais partie c'est
météorologistes ya un côté suicidaire
chez elle et sa soeur d'ouragan
monsieur on est confiné à cause de la
tempête avec je vais vous demander de
faire demi-tour au travail
a bordeaux des festivités - pontacq
[ __ ] qu'est-ce qu'ils fassent tous en
train de voler le fric
tu as besoin de moi je suis la seule à
connaître le code des parcs avec mon
frère aux estives et je dois aller on va
sauver le mans c'est quoi ce personnel
je suis citoyen d'alabama
on va être emporté par la plus grosse
compétition
j'avais bien que ça allait être une
journée cruciale
[Musique]
m
knight intervalles
harper
c'est l'acteur nice
[Musique]
c'est pas gagné
les angles j'espère
allez on emmène
machin va nous bouffer tout cru
quel temps le sien ouais
elle contient